the problem with the phrase work-life
balance is that it connotes trade-off
right so in the world of work-life
balance it's zero-sum your work and the
rest of your life so you could be doing
really great in your work you're getting
more money more power or more
responsibilities more challenge and
what's wrong with this picture what's
wrong with this picture is what's
happening here the rest of your life is
not doing too well so the idea with
balance is that when you think in terms
of an equilibrium you're always thinking
about how you can trade one for the
other and I prefer to think instead
about the idea of harmony or integration
and the pursuit of what I call four-way
wins so that means for you to think
about where is it possible where do I
have a degree of control to be able to
make things a little bit better for me
personally my mind body and spirit also
for my family however you define that
for your community and for your work and
your career so it's about looking for
opportunities to make things better at
work at home in the community and for
yourself a four-way win rather than
assuming that you've got to trade one
for the other and I find that when you
take that point of view when you put on
a set of lenses that you know allows you
to look for where is there possibility
in my world to make a positive impact in
all the different parts of my life well
then you're much more likely to find
them aren't you
then if you would just assume that they
don't exist so what we found from
research in the field with real people
and all different kinds of organizations
and at every different stage of life is
that what it takes to lead the life you
want to pursue these four-way wins there
are three principles that are critical
the first is to be real which is to act
with authenticity by clarifying what
matters most to you your vision and
values
to be whole which means to act with
integrity as one right the the latin
root of the word integrity is one so
respecting the whole the different parts
of your life your work as well as your
community your family and your personal
life and then to be innovative to act
with creativity by continually
experimenting with how you get things
done constantly learning through trial
and error challenging the status quo in
looking for better ways to get things
done that work for you and for the world
around you
so those three principles are critical
to be real to be whole and to be
innovative most of us are striving to
create a greater sense of harmony and it
is indeed in the pursuit of doing
something meaningful with the gifts the
talents the passions that you've got and
converting whatever it is that you've
been born with and continually learning
how to you know bring it to the world in
a more productive and fruitful way that
is what I discovered in my most recent
book the key to leading the life you
want it's kind of a paradox by taking
what you have and finding ways of making
it useful in the service of other people
that's how we end up leaving the lives
that we want